and you said you're not running for
president I wonder there's not much time
left you should maybe consider running
for
president and why not do it why not why
what's the argument to be so successful
so rich so intellectually curious and
not do what the country needs you to do
is get in the arena we need you Mr doio
get in the arena who wants him in the
arena
let's go nice and generous compliment
thank you very much why seriously on a
personal level take me through it well
okay Mario uh I would give up my life
for the country okay okay but um Mario
dragi in Italy if you know the
story um he knows the system and how it
works and that if you don't have
United and and operating in that
way um everybody's going to be torn
apart and so I think whatever thoughts I
have if these are helpful thoughts I I
think my best role is to pass along
whatever helpful thoughts I have and
then the population as a whole deals
with those thoughts so I'm making my
best contribution that I can I feel
that's my best capacity and then that's
up to the people